>> Sean: SO THE CHILD MEDIA
MOB AGAIN PARTICULARLY LIKE THE
EVERY DO EVERY SECOND OF EVERY
24-HOUR DAY, SHAMELESSLY
ATTACKING THE PRESIDENT FOR THE
TRAGIC MASS SUITING IN TEXAS BUT
NOT THE ONE IN OHIO.
NO.
BECAUSE THAT SHOOTER SUPPORTED
ELIZABETH WARREN AND WAS A HUGE
SOCIALIST BUT THEIR HYPOCRISY IS
BEING EXPOSED BY WHAT THEY ARE
NOT TALKING ABOUT.
WE HAVE CHRONICLED ON THE SHOW
MANY, MANY TIMES, A LOT DURING
THE OBAMA YEARS, BIG LIBERAL
CITY, RUN BY LIBERALS FOR
DECADES AND DECADES AND DECADES.
THE CITY OF CHICAGO.
THIS PAST WEEKEND, WELL, YEAH,
ANOTHER WEEKEND, A LOT OF GUN
VIOLENCE, SEVEN PEOPLE KILLED,
52 OTHER PEOPLE WOUNDED.
ONE CHICAGO HOSPITAL COULDN'T
EVEN KEEP UP.
THEY HAD TO TURN PATIENTS AWAY.
PATIENTS THAT WERE SHOT.
WE SENT OUR OWN LAWRENCE JONES,
OUR INVESTIGATIVE REPORTER AND
CORRESPONDENT TO THE WINDY CITY
TO TALK TO PRESIDENTS ABOUT WHAT
HAS BEEN GOING ON THERE FOR A
LONG TIME THAT THE MEDIA DOESN'T
TALK ABOUT.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO THIS WEEKEND, WE SAW TWO
SHOOTERS THEY GOT NATIONAL MEDIA
COVERAGE, EL PASO AND DAYTON.
BUT CHICAGO HAD A DEADLY
SHOOTING IS WELDED WHY ISN'T
CHICAGO GETTING THE ATTENTION
LIKE THE REST OF THE CITIES ARE?
>> I THINK THAT PEOPLE HAVE
GOTTEN USED TO THIS BEING
SYNONYMOUS WITH CHICAGO.
IT SAID.
THAT'S ALL I GOT TO SAY.
>> WHY DON'T YOU THINK IT'S
BEING COVERED RIGHT NOW?
BECAUSE I DON'T CARE.
IT'S A RACE THING IN MY OPINION.
I DON'T CARE.
>> DO YOU THINK PEOPLE CARE
ABOUT CHICAGO QUESTION MIGHT THE
NATIONAL MEDIA CARES ABOUT
CHICAGO BENCHMARKS BECAUSE THEY
DON'T CARE THEY DON'T.
>> WHAT ABOUT YOUR ELECTED
LEADERS QUESTION MY >> NOTHING
THERE NONE OF THEM.
THEY JUST WANT THE CHECK IN MY
OPINION.
THEY'RE OLD, THEY NEED      NEED
THEY'RE OLD, THEY NEED      NEET
THEY'RE OLD, THEY NEED      NEEO
RETIRE.
>> I DON'T SEE IT CHANGING REAL
SOON.
>> WHY NOT?
>> BECAUSE IT'S A BREAKDOWN OF
THE FAMILY UNIT.
>> YOU LOOK AT WHERE WE ARE,
WHAT IS CHANGE?
THINGS HAVE GOTTEN PROGRESSIVELY
WORSE.
HOW CAN WE SOLVE THIS ISSUE?
>> BRING IN THE NATIONAL GUARDS.
PUT THEM ON THE STREET AND GIVE
US A CURFEW AND THAT'S THE ONLY
THING I COULD THINK OF IF THEY
BRING IN THE NATIONAL GUARD.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW, JOINING US
WITH REACTION COME OUR SCORE
CORRESPONDENT INVESTIGATOR
LAWRENCE JONES BRADY NOAH, A
COUPLE WORDS SHOULD OUT.
IT'S SAD.
THEY DON'T CARE.
WHEN OBAMA WAS ITS PRESIDENT,
TOOK THE TIME ON THIS PROGRAM
AND A SHORT LAST NAME.
WE SCROLLED THE NAMES.
AND IT WENT ON AND ON AND ON.
WE DID THIS TRYING TO CALL
ATTENTION, BRING ATTENTION TO
ALL OF THESE PEOPLE SHOTS, MANY
OF THEM MURDERED, NOBODY EVER
TALKS ABOUT THEM.
52 PEOPLE SHOT, SEVEN DEAD.
WHY DO WE NOT TALK ABOUT OUR
FAMILIES IN CHICAGO AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY, WHY THE HILL DON'T
WE FIX IT?
BECAUSE RUDY GIULIANI FIXED IT
IN NEW YORK.
>> IT SOUNDED VERY CLEAR THAT
THE SOUTH SIDE OF CHICAGO ARE
TREATED NOW AT THE LIKE THE
STEPCHILDREN OF AMERICA.
IT'S VERY SAD.
THEN NUMBERS ARE ACTUALLY NOW UP
TO 59 PEOPLE THAT WERE SHOT IN
CHICAGO.
OF COURSE, SEVEN PEOPLE KILLED.
THE REST OF THE FEAR IS THAT
THEY ARE OUTRAISED NOT JUST
BECAUSE OF THE SHOOTING THAT IS
HAPPENING BUT THIS ECONOMICS
BUT WHEN YOU HAVE THREE
SHOOTINGS THAT ACTUALLY HAPPEN
OVER THE WEEKEND AND ONLY TWO OF
THEM GET THE COVERAGE, YOU
EXPLAIN WHY THAT WASN'T COVERED.
I THINK THEY HAVE A LOT TO TALK
ABOUT, A LOT OF THE RESIDENTS
DIDN'T EVEN WANT TO GO ON CAMERA
BECAUSE THEY WERE AFRAID THAT
THEY WOULD BE SHOT AS A RESULT
OF COMING ON CAMERA.
A LOT OF THE LEADERS HERE HAVE
SOMETHING TO ANSWER FOR.
I ACTUALLY GOT THE PLACE OF THE